the the very first experience
was and i don't talk about this very
often but you ask so i will
uh i was electrocuted when i was five
years old
and burned severely burned all my
eyebrows my eyelashes
all all i still have scarves in my arms
from it
uh obviously i lived and in those days
the doctor used to come to the house
in in missouri i was in northern
missouri it was in broad daylight now i
remember i
i had i had had this jolt
of electricity that shot through my body
and i couldn't talk um i was
not really paralyzed but i for whatever
reason i couldn't speak
my mom had called the doctor i was
waiting for the doctor and while i was
waiting for the doctor in broad daylight
i began
seeing in my room beings surrounding me
that were helping my body to heal from
from the shock
so that experience
at five years old you don't know what to
call that but it
told me it literally shocked me into an
awareness
that i was not alone in the world and
that there are worlds that exist that i
couldn't see
under normal circumstances and
the only way i could see those worlds
was if i had the feeling that i had
through that electrical jolt
and that experience stayed with me and
as i moved through life i learned
that that feeling the power of of my
ability
to have a feeling when i wanted to have
a feeling
to be able to to feel that connection
and communicate if i needed to
communicate with whatever those beings
were
coming from the dysfunctional family
i uh security and safety
was a big thing and i i began studying
martial arts really early in my life
and one of my first martial arts
experiences in the dojo
we had three minutes of meditation and
my instructor he stopped right at three
minutes and i said
i was in meditation and i said can we do
this a little bit longer
i remember he looked at me he said son
he said this is a karate class
if you want meditation you're in the
wrong place
but it taught me then to go seek out
teachers and they're in the u.s
meditation in the 1960s was considered
to be a cult
as as as was yoga they didn't think
about the way we do today
so i had to seek these things out and i
began putting all of this together
through the meditations i could have the
feeling that i had
when i was younger and i could i could
commune
i was never directed by
other worlds but i felt that i could
commune
and when i had questions about
what was right or wrong in my life i had
a place to go
and what i would call what i i
personally would call a very strong soul
compass
and that soul compass was with me all
through the 60s
it was a good it was a good time to have
a soul compass
uh and i was in my first band when i was
14 years old you know we were playing it
was illegal for me i was only 14 and we
were playing in clubs
and my sole compass guided me
to enjoy the music but it guided me into
safety when it came to all the excess
that was happening
with my band mates some of them died
from uh you know from the excess of the
60s so
all this to say wasn't a single
experience it was a series uh
and a progression from early in life of
knowing that there are worlds
that we're simply not taught about in
our society
that i'm related to that are with me
places to go for knowing and for
knowledge and for comfort and solace and
times of loss
and deep hurt which comes from a
dysfunctional alcoholic family
and and also guided me into
you know music was a powerful refuge for
me as was science those were my
my two for science nature and music were
my forms of
of refuge and that if i'm honest i would
have to say they probably still are
today in different ways
so those fundamental principles followed
me
in uh and i learned to access them in
more adult ways
through through my life but there was
not like a single
transcendental moment where my life made
this quantum leap from
boom one thing to another it was this
progression
long answer to a short question no no
kind of sounds like it happened at five
i mean you've been obviously you don't
collect as much information as you have
and as much awareness as you have
and um would you even say that perhaps
you
you know i definitely would subscribe to
the idea that we come into this world
and we have amnesia of where we came
from and what we are
and i think that there are some that
have a better
better trust or level of just
trusting that knowing or unknowing in
this life
and so maybe there was something that
either came in from the beginning
or happened at five years old but i
think
you know having an experience with
beings is a
extremely powerful one and the fact that
you remember it means
that it means something well by the time
the guy the doctor got to the house
i didn't really need that i mean i don't
know how much detail you want they're i
mean they were literally they were they
were very tall they were in the room
with me they were
in one at my feet and my bed
this is the mind blower for me my bed
was in the corner up against the wall
and one of those beings was standing
behind me and i remember thinking how
can
there be somebody standing behind me
there's a wall there you know and that i
mean that's the way the mind works
so uh i think we do
come in with a little bit of a blank
slate
to some degree and what i know
is from a very young age you know i did
i love the people this world so much
danica and and i love this world and
i've always wanted to be able to
contribute
in some way whatever time i have in this
world
and as a kid you do that in the way you
know how to do as a kid
and you know as a teenager you know how
to do you do it
you know for me it was through music as
a teenager and
and now it's uh through information and
knowledge to help us
to help there's so much fear i mean i
believe most people are really good
people that's my experience
and when we go into fear we can become
the most horrible beings because we will
stop at
nothing to feel safe and defend
ourselves from what we fear
and you can try to
impose change upon that fear
it doesn't work and i think we we have
seen that in the world to me the
fundamental key
is to alleviate the fear and you do that
through and we've all heard this
knowledge is power
the better we know ourselves the less we
will fear